voilà je vais vous amener dans mon
jardin
en fait je vais commencer cette petite
je vais vous raconter quelques petites
histoires pour finir la soirée
la première histoire c'est mon jardin de
mon enfance mes parents ni la bonne idée
de louer un appartement dans la très bel
endroit au rez-de-chaussée il y avait un
magnifique jardin avec des petits
chemins en terre des fleurs un jardin
potager
moi j'avais un tricycle en bois visa
gloria je me rappelle encore et puis on
faisait les fours étaient 3 on était
trois gamins là il y avait le petit
frère avait encore 1 le voisin du dessus
on a vécu la pire en réfléchissant un
peu parce que cette soirée m'a permis de
regarder les choses un peu différemment
je me suis dit peut être que c'est là
dans ce jardin que j'ai pris goût à
toutes ces choses que j'ai eu la chance
de de pouvoir contribuer à réaliser
derrière il y avait le jardinier du home
lui lave en cours un plus grand jardin
ils avaient ils avaient des cochons des
poules des lapins
puis les grandes serres avec des
plantons qu'en fait tu sortais de
l'école j'allais chez lui puis j'avais
encore un petit bout de nature et après
j'avais un papa as extraordinaire lui
l'été aux amis de la nature ça existe
toujours ils ont des cabanes pas trop
dans la montagne
et ils en ont construit du côté des
colons parfaite c'était un ami de la
nature il m'a fait visiter à peu près
toutes les cabales du valais on allait
cueillir les chanterelles du côté du
week-end enfin je crois qu'il m'a donné
cette envie qui était un peu diffuse
mais à la fin de mes études tout d'un
coup premier truc je le fais un mandat
pour l'état du valais guides valaisans
pour l'énergie solaire pour les communes
pour inciter les conseillers combien
nous accepter que les gens mettent
quelques mètres carrés de panneaux
solaires sur leur toiture
c'était le premier mandat puis tout d'un
coup ben je crois que le fil rouge il
était posée puis depuis ce moment là
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en cour demain puis
la semaine prochaine et les mois qui
viennent et puis les années qui viennent
finalement il me semble que ma mission
ça va être de continuer sur cette route
qu'après je me suis dit bon il était il
était chouette ce jardin il était
chouette ce quartier après j'essaie de
réfléchir c'était comment à l'époque
puis je me suis quand même rendu compte
que ont posé les poubelles dans la
maison les ochsner en métal et puis
après j'ai appris que ces poubelles
elle allait au bord du rhône ne purent
n'y mettez le feu donc on triait pas
tellement tellement les déchets le
traitement des eaux usées les cèpes chez
nous elles datent de 1970 moi je suis né
un peu avant
donc quand j'étais gamin les eaux usées
c'était des eaux usées donc elle est
allée au rhône
la route principale du valais la route
cantonale elle traversé le grand pont
elle montait de côté de plata puis je me
rappelle qui roulait à 60 à leur pic
pour aller à l'école c'était très très
dangereux et puis qui avait des camions
énorme md e clip avec la pollution pas
possible et je me suis dit le petit
jardin idyllique mais peut-être qu'on a
oublié c'est que dans notre ville dans
nos villes
à l'époque ce n'était pas comme
aujourd'hui alors ça m'a donné un petit
peu envie quand je dis que tout va bien
chez évidemment pas naïf mais en fait
ces temps-ci j'entends que des choses
catastrophiques
rien ne va c'est la fin du monde la
planète est perdu on va tous mourir
demain
il ya des mamans tout jaune qui renonça
hors des enfants parce qu'elles pensent
que ils n'auront pas d'avenir sur ces
planètes et ça moi ça me convient
vraiment pas ça fait 40 ans qu'on
travaille en tout cas autour de nous ici
dans le valais en suisse je pense en
europe aussi
donc je voulais vous rappelez de trois
choses qui ont été faites parce qu'un
enfant qui n'est aujourd'hui il connaît
le monde aujourd'hui connaît pas ce
monde que j'ai connu la qui était pas
aussi idyllique que ça en tout cas en
terme de pollution de l'air
donc j'avais envie de vous rappeler de
trois choses alors bon on a une usine
d'incinération qui fait de l'électricité
qui fait de la chaleur qui va chauffer
les laboratoires de monsieur le
professeur qui s'est exprimé tout à
l'heure
ah la la rue de l'industrie on traite
nos zones qui vont au lac notre lac sais
pas si vous vous rappelez mais l'époque
il y avait radio via puis beaucoup de
phosphates et on a mis beaucoup de
phosphate dans son élément
puis après bomba le phosphate c'est un
engrais donc nos petites vagues ont
poussé excessivement être consommé de
l'oxygène le lac était complètement le
trophies et donc le léman hilal est
extrêmement mal
aujourd'hui il a des problèmes de
microparticules de plastique mais pour
le reste cet été j j'y suis allé très
souvent tout baigné il est juste
magnifique
on a de l'eau claire jusqu'à 3-4 mètres
de profondeur on a un lac dans la
qualité
il ya sûrement encore des progrès à
faire toujours en fait au niveau du
traitement de l'eau on a fait des
progrès vous avez une photo là derrière
moi c'est un bout de forêt donc sur le
compte de turon cette forêt elle n'était
pas comme ça avant parce qu'il ya
beaucoup moins d'arbres
du coup il ya de la lumière du coup il
ya de la végétation au sol
du coup j'ai été tout à l'heure ce matin
j'ai vu passer trois biche des petites
villes qui se promènent à l'époque
c'étaient des arbres serrés les uns
contre les autres le sol était acide il
n'y avait pas de diversité
ce bois il est parti à lui tôt on ya
fait des pelles et cp les wanzers
réchauffe les stations donc en fait on a
fait d'une pierre trois coups
et entre lutaud la steppe val pelles et
le chauffage à distance qui va à l'école
d'ingénieurs le léman qui va mieux je
pourrais chanel on glisse c'est pas le
but de faire un tableau de chasse mais
en fait j'ai envie de vous dire quand on
vous interpelle qu'est ce que vous avez
fait vous pouvez aussi répondre nous
ensemble nous tous dans le valais
central par exemple ou dans le valais on
a mis plus de 100 millions pour faire en
sorte que l'eau que l'air que nos zones
de rencontre nos centres villes soit
plus agréable à vivre
queneau projet d'agglo se fasse puis
améliore les transports en commun que
nos cadences de vue sont accélérées pour
la ville de sion les cinq cadence de bus
à coups de millions et demi par année
mais elle permet aux gens de bramois
d'uvrier pour la morge de rejoindre le
centre ville avec des transports en
commun adf à la décadence qui sont bien
améliorées donc en fait ce que j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est oui il reste
sûrement encore beaucoup à faire
oui la planète a sûrement
souffert de ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
maintenant mais au fait nous tous nous
avons consommé de l'eau chaude
nous avons chauffer nos maisons nous
avons roulé en voiture on va aller on
n'a jusqu'à maintenant pas eu tellement
le choix de faire comme de faire comme
ça de façon essentielle
donc tous ensemble on a contribué à cet
effet que ya trop de co2 dans notre
atmosphère mais on éco responsable c'est
derrière
est ce qu'il faut faire maintenant c'est
d'abord s'appuyer sur le fait que depuis
les années 80 on a fait pas mal de
choses on n'a pas tout fait mais on a
fait pas mal de choses qu'à partir de
maintenant il faut continuer ensemble à
faire encore d'autres choses qui sont
possibles on a vu tout à l'heure avec le
professeur de lait psl que finalement si
on continue sur la voie sur la colonne
il faut pas attendre un siècle ou bien
40 ans pour que des choses changent
après j'ai envie de vous parler un tout
petit peu de l'europe sur le plan
européen il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses
je vous parle que sous le niveau énergie
parce qu'on pourrait parler sur tous les
domaines
il s'y passe partout dans tous les
domaines il s'est passé des choses
vraiment assez extraordinaire en europe
aujourd'hui il ya 80 équivalent
centrales nucléaires en puissance de
l'énergie qui est produit par des
éoliennes la journée en europe ya du
vent et en plus c'est encore du soleil
puis en balayant cours de l'eau donc
avec ses 3 3 ensemble on a on a vraiment
des quantités d'énergie énorme
après il faut les régler dans la durée
c'est clair que y'a pas toujours du vent
du soleil et de l'eau mais pour prendre
l'éolien la journée il ya parfois trop
d'énergie avant d'être arrêté les
machines à laver à midi aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt le contraire mettez tout en
route parce qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
d'énergie sur le réseau
et puis une éolienne ça s'arrête pas
comme ça un robinet de une valve une
vanne de fermeture ou d'ouverture d'un
barrage ou d'un aménagement
hydroélectrique ça peut encore se
piloter assez rapidement quelques
minutes mais une éolienne il faut
presque une demi-heure pour l'arrêter il
faut de nouveaux presqu'une demi-heure
pour la relance et puis quand elle
tourne elle tourne
messieurs qui veut qui devrait l'arrêter
parce qu'à trop d'énergie sur le réseau
il demande l'autorisation de continuer
mais y paye comme on paye l'argent
négatif quand on a
des dépôts qui se font à la banque
fédérale donc aujourd'hui on a trop
d'énergie la journée donc on peut en
faire un bon usage on peut on peut par
exemple être développé encore des
véhicules électriques pas seulement des
véhicules individuels des véhicules en
les portages des transports en commun
veut moi j'ai pensé à ça l'autre jour
pourquoi pas des tracteurs agricoles
parce que faire du bio avec des
tracteurs aux 10 elle gérer mais
personne n'a parlé de ça mais peut-être
qu'il ya moyen de faire un tout petit
peu mieux
puis un tracteur ça roule pas vite c'est
très grand pour aller m même si c'est
des batteries un peu lourde
bon il a mis des batteries au plomb à
mon collègue il ya des batteries bien
meilleure que sa main d'amélie
bien sûr il roule pour l'hydrogène alors
ça ça change rien au problème que le
véhicule électrique il ay des batteries
pour avancer ou l'hydrogène il reste un
véhicule électrique
après si on peut faire mieux sur
l'autonomie tant mieux quoi donc sur le
plan européen si vous voulez se passe
des choses qu'un très intéressante on à
moi j'aurais jamais pensé dans les
années 80 on faisait les premières
installations solaires photovoltaïques
on faisait 3000 kilowattheure c'est la
consommation d'un ménage
aujourd'hui on voit qu'en europe il y
aura il ya des puissance colossale
il ya des quantités d'énergie il faut
faire un très bon usage
mais ces quantités d'énergie elles sont
là puis même sur le plan mondial
c'est vrai qu'il ya des choses
aberrantes qui se passe c'est vrai que
les chinois pendant longtemps ils ont
vécu d'une façon totalement
irresponsable
y compris dans l'industrie pour produire
à bon marché ils ont été absolument pas
respectueux de l'environnement mais ils
sont en train de se rendre compte que
ben la nature concentrent les choses
puis qu'on peut pas dissoudre sa dans
l'environnement puisque il ya un retour
de manivelle qui est extrêmement
copieuse et cher donc on voit que par
exemple dans le domaine de la mobilité
g j'ai lu ça mais je suis pas certain
que j'ai pas vérifié 1
mais j'ai lu que les chinois avaient
quasi interdit la vente de deux
nouvelles voitures qui avance avec du
carburant ou qu'en tout cas il fallait
faire un tirage au sort pour le droit
d'en avoir une upi club
la voiture de base celle qu'on vous
offre celle que vous allez chercher sur
le marché chinois
c'est une voiture électrique alors elle
arrive encore pas sur le marché européen
et américain parce que l est pas dans
les normes en trop dans le domaine des
crash tests
c'est assez important pour la sécurité
nommé
en fait j'essaie de vous donner un ça
vous fait d'être sourire mais ils vont
pas faire long pour nous amener des
petites voitures pas cher qui roule bien
qu'ils seront qui seront faut pas
compris que trop parce qu'ils vont plus
vite que nous parce que ils ont des ils
ont des systèmes nous ont fait un
télécabine depuis cinq ans maintenant
puis on encore pas fini alors les zones
d'appel de sources les zones de
glissement les différentes choses qu'il
faut respecter
on a tellement de loi chez nous que pour
avancer d'une façon drastique
et puis et efficace comme on devrait le
faire c'est pas tout à fait évident
alors voilà le le temps qui est juste là
devant moi passe très très vite
j'aurais tellement de choses à vous
raconter mais ce que j'ai envie de vous
dire c'est que au niveau mondial
j'étais à tokyo la vie près la ville
principale c'était la plus polluées du
monde aujourd'hui c'est une rue paisible
avec des piétons avec des taxes hybride
avec une qualité de vie assez phénoménal
donc les chinois les grandes villes
on m'a parlé de new york tout à l'or qui
a considérablement changé je pense que
la plupart des grandes villes vont
vraiment vers une qualité de vie et ils
font pas seulement au niveau de la
mobilité aussi d'amener au niveau
qualité urbanistique de faire des grands
j'ai vu à tokyo dans les cartes et les
nouveaux qui se construisent un immense
soins qui est donné aux espaces entre
les bâtiments où il ya vraiment des très
beaux espaces arborisé des espaces
publics
après je voulais aussi vous dire cette
crise du climat
elle pourrait aussi être la cause non
pas de l'homme mais d'une dizaine de
volcans qui décident de s'allumer qui si
c'était le cas nous on devrait s'adapter
et en fait à l'époque on était nomade
maintenant on s'est tous arrêtés sur
place et puis on a été tous se mettre au
même endroit puis ça pose quelques
problèmes et je pense qu'on est on va
vers une période où on va devoir de
nouveau être un peu plus souple et puis
surtout face à la crise et pas faire des
reproches et se diviser et se mettre
ensemble
et puis voir ce qu'on peut faire pour
améliorer les choses donc il ya eu déjà
des crises majeures je veux pas les
évoquer maintenant y compris celle des
dinosaures est à 60 millions d'années
lui ils ont carrément disparu
je voulais vous dire aussi un tout petit
mot sur le fait que c'est un domaine
tout à fait différent mais ce fait
qu'elle ait des progrès énormes de
données de la médecine
moi j'ai la chance d'être ici
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a réussi avec
des petites cellules souches qui sont
restés quatre ans dans l'azoté liquide à
me redonner la santé
et puis ça c'est un progrès de la
médecine c'est un progrès c'est un vrai
progrès comme dans tous les domaines
l'homme il a fait des choses magnifiques
et il faut pas perdre de vue ces
choses-là pas partir dans ce cette
espèce de panique que j'ai l'impression
de vivre autour de nous j'ai aussi envie
de vous dire qu'il fort du plaisir faire
des gestes écologistes ou écologiques ou
respectueux de l'environnement ça peut
être sympa moi sorti de l'hôtel de ville
est rentré chez moi en vélo c'est
drôlement plus sympa en passant la
passerelle sous le rhône que de partir
en à pied chercher une voiture dans un
parking puis avoir quelques soucis avec
ça donc je pense que le plaisir ça peut
être un moteur extrêmement important il
ya aucun geste intelligent bien pensé
qui peut pas apporter aussi du plaisir à
l'être humain donc finalement entre la
chance que j'ai d'être en vie la chance
l'optimisme que j'ai de voir que je
crois en l'homme je crois en ingénieur
au service des hommes et puis je pense
que si tous ensemble on s'y met on
pourrait extrêmement rapidement
mais ça veut dire qu'on changerait assez
profondément notre façon de voir le
monde mais on pourrait assez facilement
des débouchés dans un monde qu'ils
forment un vaste forêt moi elle me plaît
à se former et puis ça c'est tout près
de chez nous ça c'est le jardin
d'aujourd'hui vous pouvez y aller quand
vous voulez c'est juste à notre portée
puisque d'une qualité assez
exceptionnelle
alors j'ai envie de vous dire si vous
rêvez seul ça va rester un rêve si on
rêve ensemble ça pourrait devenir une
réalité
[Applaudissements]